[Musique]
bonsoir à tout ça nous sommes le
mercredi 21 septembre vous regardez le
cette fuite le journal je suis ravi de
vous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
édition commence tout de suite avec les
titres aujourd'hui vingt troisième
édition de la journée mondiale alzheimer
reportage à plaisir ou un événement est
organisé pour la deuxième année
consécutive le thème des déchets les
aidants côté transports le earth et
s'embellit de nouvelles rames aux
couleurs de versailles vont être mis en
service pour le plus grand bonheur était
passager siens et enfin il aura fallu
attendre trois ans mais le gymnase des
pyramides et finalement rénové nouvelles
installations et les nouvelles normes
nous y reviendrons et un grand
rassemblement des présidents des
départements et des élus a eu lieu
aujourd'hui à paris devant l'assemblée
nationale
le but de ce rassemblement était
d'alerter l'état sur les coupes
drastiques des dotations de l'état qui
les étouffe nous y reviendrons demain
plus longuement dans le journal et la
23e édition de la journée mondiale
d'alzheimer se tenait aujourd'hui un peu
partout en france
cette année la problématique des aidants
professionnels étaient au coeur des
actions menées et notamment à l' hôpital
gérontologique et médico social de
plaisir je vous propose de regarder ce
reportage signé kourina falun et nicolas
kirillovitch stress fatigue isolement ou
encore vie personnelle en suspens le
quotidien des aidants professionnels est
devenue une vraie problématique de la
maladie d'alzheimer ainsi indirectement
aujourd'hui trois millions de personnes
sont concernées par la pathologie en
france les deux tiers des patients
vivent à domicile dont un tiers quand
même dans un état dans une état sévère
quand même donc beaucoup à domicile et
donc c'est les aidants c'est grâce aux
aidants
qui peuvent rester à domicile c'est la
famille qui les entoure a les dents qui
est soutenu ça change beaucoup parce
qu'à directement ça ça joue sur le
patient et pour évoquer justement les
difficultés des aidants de nombreux
événements étaient organisés dans les
structures médico sociales et notamment
à l'hôpital de plaisir grignon pour la
deuxième année consécutive notre filière
qui est composé d'un hôpital qui fait
médecine aiguë et est nécessaire ou les
patients qui sont hospitalisés un
hôpital de jour où les patients qui sont
domicile qui peuvent bénéficier d'une
prise en charge
or dans cet hôpital est aussi les
accueils de jour que c'est une structure
qui va aussi permettre de prolonger la
prise en charge de ces patients qui sont
dans un état évoluer de la pathologie
selon un sondage réalisé par france
alzheimer près de 80% des ide en
rencontrent des difficultés à associer
leur vie professionnelle et leur
activité d'accompagnement et on revient
à présent à sur les journées portes
ouvertes cote du théâtre esat eurydice
l'événement s'est déroulé le vendredi 16
et le samedi 17 septembre le théâtre en
a profité pour présenter sa saison mais
aussi pour faire découvrir ses
différentes activités d'ateliers de
théâtre et de décors mais également un
atelier de services aux entreprises les
personnes en situation de handicap
employé par les aides travaille
également à des activités d'industrie
électrique de reprographie et de mise
sous pli on écoute tout de suite richard
leteurtre le directeur il était au micro
de camille lambert le but effectivement
c'est toujours de continuer à se faire
connaître auprès des gens qui pourraient
postuler ici auprès de clients qui
pourrait faire appel à nous auprès de
spectateurs pour
avoir envie de venir voir nos spectacles
voilà auprès de compagnies comme jouer
chez nous oui effectivement on est un
lieu où la communication est très
importante du fait de la particularité
artistique
mais du fait aussi que c'est un lieu qui
travaille plutôt sur l'innovation sur
l'innovation sociale d'innovations
techniques et les théâtres l esat
eurydice a également travaillé pour le
festival deux êtres orphée et viva la
vida qui débute le 27 septembre un
festival qui mêle art et handicap nous
vous en reparlerons enfin une bonne
nouvelle à présent pour les passagers de
la ligne du rer c plusieurs rames de la
ligne ans décoré aux couleurs du château
de versailles comme vous le voyez sur
ces images c'est la quatrième année que
la sncf et le château travail d'ensemble
pour faire rêver les franciliens mais
aussi les touristes lors de leur trajet
pour l'instant deux rames sont décorées
trois autres le seront en début d'année
prochaine
écoutez catherine pégard la directrice
du château à était au micro de nicolas
kirillovitch nous on a deux objectifs
que s'il s'agit des touristes les
touristes qui viennent à versailles
ils commencent leur visite et ils rêvent
de versailles avant d'y arriver et le
soir quand ils repartent ils gardent le
souvenir de versailles est un peu plus
longtemps en prenant le train et pour
tous ceux qui prennent le rer en effet
pour aller à leur travail
je pense que ça peut outre le fait que
ça leur donne une atmosphère apaisée je
pense aussi que ça peut donnent leur
donner l'idée de revenir à vinça et de
venir visiter versailles qui connaissent
déjà et taxis à hydrogène agir au lift
ou encore un atelier vélo participatif
voilà ce qu'on pouvait découvrir à
versailles grand parc et dimanche
dernier à l'occasion de la semaine de la
mobilité focus sur les nouveautés de la
mobilité de demain et notamment sur le
vélo à hydrogène avec le sma neuf
vendeurs des et nicolas thivel aux beats
à travers des animations des
démonstrations également des essais le
public a pu découvrir les innovations et
avancées technologiques de demain
notamment le smart grid développé par
vider comme et à deux types de stockage
un stockage court terme c'est à dire par
exemple tout simplement en rechargeant
les batteries d'un véhicule électrique
tout comme vous rechargez les batteries
de votre smartphone tous les jours c'est
un moyen de stocker de l'énergie
c'est un stockage court terme
à côté on travaille sur un stockage long
terme qui est par exemple fabriquer de
l'eau en hydrogène
alors pourquoi fabriquer de l'hydrogène
nous direz vous simplement aujourd'hui
dans les maisons on peut chauffer des
ballons d'eau chaude et c'est un moyen
de stocker l'énergie donc pourquoi pas
partir de ce moment-là transformé de
l'eau en hydrogène pour ensuite venir
alimenter une flotte de vélos
électriques qui fonctionnent à
l'hydrogène et dimanche dernier on
pouvait découvrir aussi ce vélo à
hydrogène une bicyclette qui possède une
autonomie de 100 km à attirer les
curieux
je pense que l'avenir d'autant que
l'autonomie si elle est confirmée à
hauteur de 120 km dépasse tout ce qui
existe aujourd'hui quoi
je pense qu'il ya un marché
effectivement au travers du vélib avant
que le véhicule électrique arrive sur le
sur le marché maniable il freine il
accélère comme un vélo électrique
non tout se jouera c'est en fait sur
l'autonomie et le temps de recharge
c'est le plus du vélo il faudra
patienter jusqu'en 2017 avant que le
vélo à hydrogène ne soient
commercialisés en attendant l'événement
a rassemblé environ un millier de
personnes et a été un véritable succès
sept jours sans voiture c'est le défi
qu'a lancé à la commune de chevreuse à
ses habitants du 17 au 25 septembre
c'est l'opération sept jours sans
voiture pour cette deuxième édition une
trentaine de volontaires ont été à
sélectionner camille lambert a remontré
deux de ses participants ils ont opté
pour les vélos électriques comme vous
allez le voir
sept jours sont voiture c'est le défi
que se sont lancé michael et karine ses
deux salariés du crédit agricole de
guyancourt participent à l'opération
initiée par le parc régional de la haute
vallée de chevreuse un challenge pour
favoriser l'éco mobilité
je prends beaucoup de plaisir à faire du
vélo notamment pour découvrir des
paysages comprend pas forcément le temps
de voir en voiture consultez mon
compteur de vitesse par exemple surtout
dans les pentes
l'effet bénéfique en terme d'écologie
j'habite après envoyez donc entrant
rambouillet et chartres donc j'ai un
petit peu plus de 40 kilomètres entre 40
et 45 km à faire tout ça dans la vallée
de chevreuse avec deux trois côtes
d'affaires pendant mon trajet michael
part de son domicile à 6 heures du matin
pour rejoindre son lieu de travail pour
moins de fatigue
il utilise un vélo à assistance
électrique de colibri partenaires de
l'opération et du crédit agricole depuis
deux ans on leur met à disposition une
flotte de vélos électriques
d'entreprises qui mettent à disposition
de leurs collaborateurs
c'est le vélo sans les ennuis du vélo un
donc c'est des vélos s'enchaînent sans
qu'en bruit ce nivellois cardan ça ne
crève pas celui qui crée avec le vélo
gagne le vélo on met des scènes
confortable et on et débattre avec une
grosse autonomie donc les gens les
utilisent comme un véhicule un peu sympa
à l'issue de ce paris michael et karine
prévoit de favoriser les déplacements à
vélo dans leur quotidien pour cette
deuxième édition de sept jours sans
voiture une trentaine de participants
ont tenté l'expérience et prenons à
présent la direction de
voisins-le-bretonneux après trois années
de chantier les travaux du gymnase des
pyramides sont sur le point de s'achever
l'ancien parti du gymnase âgé d'une
trentaine d'années a été remise aux
normes d'accessibilité et aux normes
énergétiques
plus de précisions dans ce reportage
démarré en juillet 2014 les travaux de
l'ancien parti du gymnase des pyramides
de voisins-le-bretonneux ont été
l'occasion de rénover le dojo la salle
de danse et le hall d'entrée mais aussi
de remettre le bâtiment aux normes quant
à son accessibilité et à sa consommation
énergétique au niveau de la rénovation
donc il a fallu tenir compte maintenant
de handicap et donc par rapport à ces
personnes tout a été bien remis aux
normes
que ce soit donc l'accès à la grande
salle si à quelques marches à descendre
pour y accéder donc avec une plateforme
handicapées un petit ascenseur et puis
bah dans tout les vestiaires surtout ne
serait ce que pour penser à la hauteur
des lavabos des différents porte
manteaux pour être accessible à ces
personnes environ 250000 personnes
parents adhérents et scolaires circulent
dans ce gymnase une extension il y avait
été installé en 2008 à voisins le
bretonneux nous avons plus de 40
associations sportives ce gymnase ne
désemplit pas les salles sont en
permanence plein
donc il ya un vrai besoin parce que
voisin avec une ville où les chinois
sont sportifs à dernière étape des
travaux dont le coût s'élève à 1,8
million d'euros
des portes coulissantes devraient être
installés à l'entrée du bâtiment d'ici
la fin du mois de septembre et on prend
un peu de hauteur pour terminer ce
journal depuis vendredi dernier pierre
farman a atterri à la maison des
bonheurs de magny les hameaux petit fils
des pionniers aviateurs il expose
actuellement des pièces en rapport avec
l aviation affiche photos et même à des
morceaux d'avion un moyen de faire
décoller son héritage comme vous le
montre
camille lambert la tête dans les nuages
la famille farman a marqué l'histoire de
l'aviation
elle fait partie des pionniers lancer à
l'assaut du ciel au début du 20e siècle
aujourd'hui le petit fils revendique son
héritage dans une exposition à magny les
hameaux
nous étions fabricants d'avions par moi
naturellement le membre en paix avec eux
donc je fais des débuts de l'aviation
premiers km en circuit fermé premier
plein de choses pour les passagers au
monde également une compagnie chapelle
air france qui est la fusion entre nos
lignes aériennes et trois autres de 1908
à 1941 les frères forman ont conçu plus
de 200 types d'avions magny les hameaux
est l'une des villes où était fabriqué
des moteurs et des pièces à la maison
des bonheurs une centaine d'objets est
exposée il ya le délit de nos avions et
le goliath qui était le premier avion de
ligne au monde et vous avez les pièces
dehors qui sont plus récentes qui
viennent de chez dassault aviation du
boeing 707 ou du falcon 50 ans c'est
l'idée de transmettre aux jeunes l'envi
de travail et l'envié de rêver
pierre farman ouvrira prochainement un
musée de l'aviation à saint-cyr-l'ecole
décollage prévu dans quelques mois est à
présent la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis je vous
donne rendez vous demain pour un nouveau
numéro du jt vous souhaite une
excellente soirée
[Musique]